well another major European country
Italy also has a new leader he gave her
first policy statement in Parliament
today Georgia Maloney is Italy's first
woman prime minister and also the
country's first leader from a far right
party since World War II Melody's speech
was closely watched for clues about
policy changes under her new coalition
government if she affirmed Italy's
strong support for Ukraine but
acknowledged that the energy crisis
resulting from Russia's War would dampen
the country's economic Outlook Maloney
also said that her government will work
towards stopping migrant boats from
setting out from North Africa
just last week a recording emerged from
Maloney's Coalition partner Silvio
Berlusconi in which he boasted about his
personal friendship with Russian
President Vladimir Putin the new prime
minister today salt in Her speech to
dispel any doubts about Rome's
commitment to Kiev
Italy will continue to be a reliable
partner within NATO supporting the brave
Ukrainian people who oppose Russia's
Invasion giving in to Putin's blackmail
on energy would not solve the problem it
would make it worse by opening the way
to further demands
a correspondent Tim mcgupta is following
the story for us tonight in Rome it's
good to have you back with us
um the new prime minister Georgia
Maloney is a she comes from a far-right
euroskeptic party
a coalition with neo-fascist roots she
says that Europe is watching her closely
so what did you make of the tone of her
speech today
well I think it was really a combative
and very Resolute speech on her part at
times even emotional particularly when
she talked about the fact that she was
the first woman prime minister the first
female to take on such a role and also
when she remembered the humble roots
that she came from uh she grew up in a
working-class neighborhood of garbatella
here in Rome uh and when she talked
about those things she got quite
emotional but overall I think she struck
the right note in terms of reassuring
her European allies she said she was
pronato she's a hundred percent behind
it uh she would support support EU rules
but making changes where she feels it
hasn't been working for a long time but
being part of the European family and
also that stance of being pro-ukraine
when it came to her neo-fascist Roots
she was also very clear saying that she
was always against any kind of uh
regimes and that would include fascism
as well you know I want to pick up um on
the topic of Ukraine again you know
there have been concerns in Brussels
other capitals around the EU about this
this new government Italy and its
commitment to backing Ukraine but
especially after this leak that we had
of comments about Putin from Silvio
Berlusconi are all three Coalition
partners are they all three firmly
committed to protecting and supporting
Ukraine
well that is the big question you're
absolutely right with that bombshell
audio tapes in which he seemed to uh
talk about recently exchanging gifts
with the Russian president and even
criticizing the Ukrainian leader
zelensky uh that really didn't bode well
for the Coalition and let's not forget
her other Coalition partner Mateo
salvini of the league party has been
known to express his admiration for
Putin in the past he's also questioned
the role of sanctions saying that in the
long run it might hurt Italians more
than actually uh damage the Russians and
so uh there is some question on that
front but miss Maloney for her partner
has made it very clear anyone who is
part of this government has to be
supporting the ukrainians and if they
are not they cannot be part of the
government at the risk of forming no
government so really at this point each
one each member of this Coalition needs
the other in order to go forward and
govern and as we saw earlier this
evening they all voted in support and
passed a vote of confidence in the lower
house
a big reason for the far-right election
win was its promise to tackle migration
I want us to take a listen to part of
what the new prime minister had to say
about that today take a listen
of course that
that stopping illegal departures as a
way of finally breaking human
trafficking in the Mediterranean
an EU option which has never been
implemented provides for blocking
departures from North Africa
Seema explain to us what the new prime
minister is thinking is here on
migration policy and is this something
that Italy can do alone or is it going
to depend on other European union
members
well what she was doing was Kelly also
speaking to her supporters and this is
an issue that is really a hot button
topic for them and she stressed that
their aim is to stop those migrant boats
as you heard stop the Smugglers and work
with governments in Africa particularly
North Africa to hop the flow creating
these so-called hot spots uh in those
countries to process Asylum requests now
this is something that's been talked
about in the past and she has made it
clear that she wants to work with Europe
on this but it's been very difficult so
far to find a common ground on this
issue and some even question the
legality of doing such a measure measure
whether such a naval blockage can even
work so really there are risks and
challenges involved in pushing such a
policy but this has been something she
has talked about throughout the election
campaign and it's something that she
wishes to continue having this
right-wing Coalition behind her let's
not forget Mateo salvini was very much
in favor of this when he was was the
interior Minister here in Italy what
about inflation you know we recently saw
images of Italian protesters burning
their energy bills I mean how much
pressure is on this new government
to tackle inflation
there's a lot of pressure with those
soaring Energy prices she knows full
well that this is a key issue for
Italians Italian families and Italian
businesses and if you want the economy
to pick up there's a risk that Italy
could go into recession in 2023 and she
acknowledged this fact and in fact said
that she may have to delay some of those
election promises as far as the economy
is concerned because this issue is
really on top of the agenda it's tough
times here in Italy she has made it
clear it's the most difficult situation
that Italy has has to face since World
War II and so because of these reasons
she feels that will be a main issue that
she has to do which is which essentially
means coming up with help for families
as well as businesses having to deal
with these really high costs in their
energy bills journalists Seema Gupta
joining us tonight from Rome as always
Seema we appreciate your reporting thank
you